last night we introduced you to the
latest addition to our global family of
Nations the hundred and ninety sixth
country on Earth we're keeping track
it's called Chaz Chaz is gleaming
capital rises from land that once
belonged to an indigenous but now nearly
extinct tribe known as the Seattle
Police Department as with so many great
nations the creation story of jazz holds
innumerable lessons for all of us it's a
tale of unlikely good fortune and the
triumph of perseverance over hardship
how do a group of people with no useful
skills no record of achievement or a
personal hygiene a group capable
smashing windows and setting fires but
nothing else how do a group like that
create an entirely new nation well
that's a question we may soon face here
in the United States in fact given our
current trajectory it's never easy to
build things with people who can only
destroy and yet Chaz pulled it off with
grit and determination this plucky
little nation managed to give birth to
itself and in the process a whole new
era of democratic self-government
okay that's overstatement they haven't
actually built anything in Chaz it's
still mostly graffiti and discarded
Starbucks cups nor is it fully a
democracy in fact the country is run by
a warlord slash rapper called Raz whose
last paying job was renting out his own
apartment on Airbnb it is in other words
a work in progress but Chaz does have
one functioning institution it's a
Department of Agriculture it's up and
running
Chaz's Danny's are a proud independent
people and they plan to feed themselves
take a look at Chaz's first collective
farm no it's not Kansas at harvest time
you don't see swaying fields of wheat
but it's a start the farmers of Chas
have big dreams they imagine several
more square feet of kale in organic
scallions planted in Dixie Cups and of
course cannabis lots and lots of stinky
indica buds for the people the chasis
Tani's may not know a lot about
agriculture but they have heart as they
often say as they work the fields if
they could do it in Jonestown we can do
it here naturally officials in nearby
Washington State have become bitterly
jealous of his thriving breakaway
republic two days ago jay Inslee
small-minded governor of Washington
pretended he had never even heard of
chats well that's news to me so I'll
have to reserve any comment about it I
have not I have not heard anything about
that never heard of Chazz as if come on
governor show us the search history on
your phone every idealistic young
pioneer in this country has been
compulsively googling Chazz for days and
you haven't please it's ridiculous the
media meanwhile and not surprising we
have missed the story completely they're
pretending Chazz isn't even a real
country they're calling it a street fair
hundreds of demonstrators have been
gathering and what is being described as
part protest zone part commune part
Street festival you know the president
called some anarchists and somebody
could call it anarchy but it's more so
to the extent that you could call it a
community takeover suggesting that the
US military would use force we're
talking about six blocks here this is
the Capitol Hill neighborhood in the
heart of Seattle we're talking about a
six block area it's much more of a
pedestrian street fair type atmosphere
you have the food trucks that are open
the favorite taco shop is open there's
couches that are out there food trucks
and a taco shop the people on television
pretend this proud independent nation is
some kind of ethnic food festival no
corporate Stooges this isn't about
pinatas and dunk tanks
this is nationhood Chaz has teeth Chaz
can bite back as one cable news reporter
discovered remember they want to see
this police department defunded or even
abolished short of some type of major
concession they're not going to leave
voluntarily and we should point out that
Washington is an open carry state and no
doubt some of these protesters are armed
Anderson so
you have to worry about the potential
for bloodshed the potential for violence
here that Chaz deniers Chaz has guns
King razz merely has to say the word and
his country's crack Special Forces teams
will emerge like ninjas from the shadows
you may not even recognize them as
soldiers some may look homeless others
may be injecting narcotics or
shoplifting but make no mistake this
army means business
they rolled over the Seattle Police
Department like Cortez conquering the
Aztecs they'll do it to you to CNN watch
out
radio host Jason Rance is our man on the
ground just across the Demilitarized
Zone from Chazz he joins us tonight
Jason thanks so much for coming on were
you able to cross the border today well
I have to tell you that they actually
realized that their border was quite
porous there were some cops who were
able to get through so they refortified
the borders that are there so that they
can keep some of these police invaders
from coming actually into their nation
so it's a little bit more difficult than
usual to get in but they have actually
confirmed that they are in fact armed
and they're keeping track of people who
are coming in and out of their nations
so they're taking their security as this
burgeoning nation very seriously but
they're obviously also having some
problems as you just showed the what
appears to be a farm that was put
together by Michael Bloomberg it
literally looks like topsoil on top of
ground that they haven't even dug up and
they realized that maybe it's gonna take
a little bit longer for them to actually
grow some of the food so they have to
say it's a process request yeah yeah
they're looking for some food gatorade
also cigarettes of course and they're
realizing that maybe they don't have
enough residents who are willing to do
some of the cleanup so of course the
city came in and actually cleaned some
of the porta-potties that were actually
delivered by the city to this new nation
so I mean it's Seattle we're stepping up
and giving some help
they're already NGOs on the ground I
mean this sounds more like a refugee
camp than it does it a proud independent
nation look what independent nation that
hasn't gone through some of these
growing pains right it's gonna they
don't really even have a leader in fact
now they're I know we mentioned Raz
Symone there's some concern that he
doesn't actually represent everyone and
it turns out there hasn't been a
election maybe there will be perhaps
they'll ask for IDs for people to vote
so I as a South Lake Union resident of
Seattle don't get a say in picking their
leader but we'll see may I ask you said
at the outset that Chas has fortified
its borders
did anybody point out that that's racist
I mean I'm pretty sure that's racist
borders are racist right they it borders
are racist but they're progressive
Seattle lights and they're very woke so
obviously if they're doing it it can't
be racist but still seems racist to me
huh you think it will be able to get in
tomorrow over the weekend that's your
privilege yeah I will try to get in over
the weekend we'll see what it actually
looks like I'm gonna try to not get a
contact high as I'm walking through as
was the case yesterday there was a lot
of weave being smoked there and someone
actually walked up to us and they said
where can we smoke and I said it's Chaz
I think you could pretty much smoke
wherever it is you want it's again oh
that's the America they're planning for
us Jason Rance outside Chaz on the DMZ
good to see you tonight
thank you